hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is Tamara's never seen but today I
am watching Beetlejuice for the first
time the only Beetlejuice content that I
have taken in is the intro to the
Beetlejuice animated series Beetlejuice
and Lydia are on like a roller coaster
and their friends and it's super cute
and cool and I'm interested in that but
that's the only thing I've not seen the
show but I'm really excited to watch
this everyone that I tell that I haven't
seen this - it's like you've never seen
this and that's the total comment that I
get online but when I see it like when
something in real life is like okay I
know you do Tamara's ever seen but you
really never seen this it's like an
indication is like alright I guess I
should really see this alright here we
go
oh I've never seen you guys don't so got
it holy crap
that was so much fun the makeup and the
practical effects were incredible and
really interesting and engaging and this
movie was shorter than most of the
movies I do for the series this was an
hour and 30 minutes and I was like oh
where did the time go I'm so stand-ins
ended so quickly damn I don't know much
about beetlejuice but um question is
there was there any content for beetle
just before this was there like a was it
like a comics or was was there any kind
of any kind of movie or cartoon or
anything before this or was my fault
Heaton just like the first Beetlejuice
ever
I'm so confused how is he vis good as a
sucker he was so funny and so engaging
and specific and it was incredible I was
saying earlier this is a Tim Burton that
everyone just adores and loves I think I
know Tim Burton for what what people
don't love Catherine O'Hara I didn't
know she was in this anytime season
anything it's going to be a GD delight
Winona Ryder I love her style I love her
attitude her acting is a point she just
just Winona Ryder yes can you imagine
being an actor and getting handed a
script
for something that's never been done
something that is like you're like wacky
just like weird this is going to be
something that's going to be great for
my resume and then you do it edit it
some things are such a gamble for actors
and so you could do something like this
and it's great or you could do something
like the room and it's like what's the
fog why did I do that
though to be fair if you were in the
room you're famous anyways though bad
example but you know what I mean Danny
Elfman amazing Danny the first thing I
wrote down was young Alec took me by
suprise they are living in this like
wonderful like vacation area and they
have a house and so cute Geena Davis
Alec Baldwin adorable couple and then
this little dog who I don't know if he
has a name but I was calling him little
scrap like least dramatic car fall from
a bridge little scrap and so I thought
this was going to be like a plot point
but it was like a d-flat point they died
they fell probably 20 feet from like a
really scenic bridge and just like this
beautiful meadow I would think I okay
they died that's fine cool they died I
wrote midnight
I am super into it so they get a
handbook for the recently deceased they
don't read it through like they should
like literally the only literature that
you have maybe give it a read no okay
but the home that they're living in gets
bought out by this awesome family Winona
Ryder as Lydia Catherine O'Hara as this
like really snooty mom I don't know his
name but it's the principal Ferris
Bueller's Day Off and some dad I also
love that I wouldn't have known who this
was if I hadn't have watched Ferris
Bueller's Day Off
so Tamara's never seen thank you what
his gift I feel so bad for him he just
wants to rule the heck I hated him so
much in Ferris Bueller's Day Off but now
I'm just like oh my gosh can you just
watch some birds buddy just watch some
birds everyone will leave him alone so
the movie goes on for quite a while
before you actually see the old juice
and when you first seem incredible you
see this commercial to like help you out
to get rid of people in your home if
you're a ghost and it's so good he's
like I'll be there anything you want to
eat swallow anything you want to swallow
right laughs also I really really really
want to do like a makeup tutorial
cosplay video on like a Beetlejuice
makeup and the receptionist for the dead
people makeup I would suck it would be
so fun though something really cool that
I I enjoy a lot is the model town a
really cool transition for like shots
like going in from the actual towns
model town is so cool it's a really
impressive model town so we would notice
tells her parents and they don't care
they don't believe her so Alec Baldwin
and his lovely wife are like well let's
call beetlejuice I guess even though
they were told not to call him because
he's the worst he comes and he's like
I've seen the Exorcist 167 times and it
gets funnier every time same Larry so
the school that I went to Rachael piece
and I went to this school there is a
party each year they've been doing it
for years and years and years and years
and years and it's called homo coming
the winner of my first year Sabrina
she's an incredible incredible cosplayer
Sisyphus Edward Scissorhands and I was
going to go with Edward Scissorhands
even though I had never seen Edward
Scissorhands and she found out that I
was gonna cook Edward Scissorhands and
she was like hey camera just want to let
you know I'm going as Edward
Scissorhands it was the kindest thing
maybe anyone's ever done for me in my
entire life because I was literally
going to take scissors onto my hand but
she looked like this point of the story
the next year she dressed up as
Beetlejuice and it was out of this world
so good to make it was incredible I
could never do that in a million years
but I really want to so look out for
that mediocre video another thing I love
is the interior decorator also Oso I
love him kiss from the get-go everything
he says is super pretentious super
annoying but anything
the afterlife is super real and super
true then you do the dinner party scene
is a many thing it's the mom it's
Catherine O'Hara she's throwing this
dinner party for all of her rich
pretentious friends and then Alibaba she
today was hot the shit out of it it was
awesome
it's hilarious and lobster attacks their
faces and then they're all super enjoy
they're like oh we love being husband
great haunting is great I'm counting on
go Alec and he achieved is just acting
leave a little to be desired you look a
little bit their reaction shots are
always like really off but they're
always look like just like a little a
little awkward my favorite line in the
entire movie was they were talking about
how they were dead and how Lydia
couldn't be with him and she was like I
want to be dead too and they go Geena
Davis goes being dead really doesn't
make anything any easier so really good
line a damn for this crazy out of this
world like nutso movie to just still
have like like a little hip go into the
message here like here you go it's
really nice Lydia's like well I mean
Beetlejuice is help and Beetlejuice like
well you got to marry me and I'll come
and then she's like all right lots of
questions and concerns here first of all
I always assumed Beetlejuice was the
good guy I just thought he was like this
like bad character that you loved he is
like I thought he was like this evil
character that like it turns out to be
the good guy you know what I'm saying I
don't know what I'm saying so how could
you know I just I really thought he was
a good guy and then he turned out to not
be the good guy and at the end I was
like wait
what yeah I wrote animated scene opening
married because they're on the roller
coaster together and that's all I've
ever seen of Lydia and Beetlejuice
together and so I thought they were like
a couple and that's what I was going
into this movie thinking that Lydia and
fielders were going to be a couple which
was weird when it first started because
he soon was older than her um so I guess
it use your reasoning Tamra but I didn't
then it ends so they make it to go back
to being their healthy ghosts cell and
then Lydia gets his really cool life
where she gets this like cool couple of
Alec and Gina their parents are now like
half-sphere some reason cuz movies and
she gets to be haunted and that's she's
like this Dartz character so of course
she was to be haunted all the time it's
awesome so cool I loved acting I loved
the cast
I loved the makeup I loved the story
also I loved if it was an hour and a
half and not freaking to it two hours
two hours 30 minutes I can leave you
wanting more versus being like oh my I
wanna is rapping yeah I loved this it
was weird and nuts and is there is there
abuses to be able to build it
Beetlejuice Ike Ike Ike she's so mad I'm
sorry we just breathe so hard
we need Maddie breathe this is weird
breast saying really that's how you know
check out my personal channel I post
every Friday there and look out for a
Beetlejuice cosplay soon and thanks for
watching
I really read hit it and I'll see you
next week
[Music]